the right-hander james caprarian the 27
year old out of southern california
making his third big league start 1-0
a 2-5-3 era 15 strikeouts in 10 and
two-thirds innings
he hits one hard backhanded alba sanders
gets up throws the first in a very nice
play to open up the ball game
by alba sanders hey good start for the
athletics the guy hits the ball hard
instead of being a base hit to center
field elvis andrews had him play
perfectly nice backhand
slide down get up and throw quickly to
first base to retire the first
hitter for the mariners nice play by
elvis anders especially playing almost
in the second base position
especially chapman
ranging to his left throws so two outs
here in the top of the first and that'll
bring up kyle seeger
first pitch to seeger line drive right
into the glove of olson and that's a
three-up three-down inning for james
caprara the right-hander robert duggar
first time the a's have seen this guy
he's
25 years of age making a second start
his eighth appearance
for the mariners no record of 4-1-5 era
now here's the 3-1 pitch and mark takes
high and that's the way the bottom of
the first begins as kenneth
works another walk there's a good curve
and olson cuts right through it
i think that gives you an idea right
there that last pitch
and the way that he could spin it up
there because this is a breaking ball
that ends up right in the middle of the
plate that is middle middle
and olsen swings through it see if
cannon takes off
he does and it is a curveball and it's
outside so it's a walk
no need for the throw to second base two
on one out so a couple of walks
so here's brownies looking for a big hit
they're two for 13 with runners in
scoring position
in this series this one's driven to left
field then it's hit well walton going
back still going back he turns around
it goes up off the wall and over the
wall so canada's gonna score they'll be
second and third
with one out seth brown drives him the
other way
yeah probably caused the azir run but
considering the way they have not been
hitting with runners in his goal
position they'll take it
so now the a's will look for more as
chapman steps in
first pitch to chapman is driven to left
field
walton over near the line and he makes
the catch
gonna be a sacrifice fly as loriano
comes in to score two to nothing
the a's lead to the second is lead two
nothing and lewis leads it off it's
lewis crawford in france for the
mariners against caprilian
shallow left field andrews out brown in
it's going to be
seth brown on the move makes the catch
and that is the swing of the miss first
strikeout for katrina
playable in left center brown has it six
up six down for james caprarian medalson
starts the third
olson high and deep to right field
kellnick looking up near the wall
reaches for the wall
and that baby's gone a towering home run
for matt olson who's 13th of the year
well they wanted it high and it got
there
but fastballs in real estate location
location location
this thing is middle and matt olson foot
down
on time pack your bags all aboard
next stop pound town
canada at second lewis at first
[Applause]
bases are loaded two out walk
taps this one slowly kemp he's got it
throws to first in time so on one pitch
walton is retired and the mariners leave
the bases loaded
so here's wyatt mills his eighth
appearance it's a's leading three to
nothing and looking for more in the
fourth they've got garcia at first
and andrew's at second and marquette at
the plate
and that one is way inside mills all
over the place and now the bases are
loaded
this one is driven toward left center
field lewis on the move lewis circling
around
and he makes the catch it's going to get
elvis anders home with a sacrifice fly
and that makes it a four to nothing game
so matt olson picks up his second rbi in
the ball game
two outs and here's l'oreal with a run
in
and that's going to fall
garcia's gonna score canada third it's
an rbi single by ramon loriano and it's
five to nothing the a's lead
that's a great event started in owen two
and just kept fighting off fighting off
ten
ten pitch at bat and finally got that
fast ball left he said dallas stayed
inside and he beat it off and
into the outfield shallow enough and if
francisco's was still around francesco's
would have had a dinner for two for
ramona mariano with a ten pitcher back
getting on base but no longer
up the middle and that's going to get
through into center field for a hit
hannah comes in to score and the clutch
hits just keep coming for the a's it's
six to nothing
and right back up through the box where
it came from
and these lefties against mills probably
not an ideal at bat just because they're
able to see this ball a little while
and a great job by brownie
just keep this line moving a couple two
out
knocks back to back
[Music]
chopping softly tough play seeger bare
hand
and plenty of time what a play
by kyle seeger and james cabrillo still
standing for the athletics which is
encouraging
he's gone six shutout frames today and
the righty's first pitch is bounced
behind first
and a big hop handled there by olson man
another easy
quick out for caprilian allowing him to
go deeper in the game
olson into foul territory and olson has
it under control
as always and he grabs it so two quick
outs here for
james capralian who is really just kind
of rolling along
[Applause]
more action for brown stops makes the
catch that's a
sixth pitch seventh inning what a job
this afternoon by james capralian t
is working on his second win of the year
romero petit will take over
for the a's it'll be his 25th appearance
campbell into the gap finds a base hit
picked up by piscotti campbell finds a
single to begin the top of the eighth
godoy lashes this to right over piscotty
almost wedged at the base of the fence
campbell first to third
godoy gave that a ride mariners have him
on the corners for kelman
as kelnick hits this off of olson
campbell comes in now here's the 2-2
pitch swung on a shot through into left
center for a base sid
that's going to score gadoy and henniger
is turning it first he's going to second
that's a double
and now it's a six to two ball game and
every ball the mariners have hit in this
inning off of petite
has been well hit see
being waved in he scores danny the
mariners have cut this lead in half
so 6-3 a's lead it is the ninth inning
deekman came in in the top of the eighth
and got the final out
he has a chance to pick up a save if he
can get through the mariners here in the
ninth inning
little pop-up alva sanders hustling out
and he
grabs it for the ball game so alva
sanders tracked it down made a nice play
and that's how the ball game comes to an
end
and these have won it and the final is
6-3 as they take care of
kelnick with two runners on base as the
rookie outfielder
without a bet was representing the tying
run